so last night as scheduled i gave my
talk at georgia tech in the lead up to
the ncaa women's swimming swimming
championship where a biological male
will compete against
and dominate uh the females i wanted to
explain why this was wrong but i i
wasn't there just talk about women's
sports i was you know there to talk
about and the whole speech is available
on my youtube channel as you'll see if
you watch it our discussion went far
beyond sports and into issues
surrounding language
biology logic basic fundamental truths
of life you know all these sorts of
things at one point in the speech i
spent about five minutes talking about
what the words male and female mean
and um explaining that men cannot have
babies and it occurred to me as i was
getting into this part of the speech how
sad and deeply tragic it is that we've
reached a point in society where a
podcaster without a college degree has
to go to colleges and give basic biology
lessons but that's where we are and
that's where i was last night
of course there were many students at
the school who who did not want me there
and
as we talked about yesterday the local
antifa chapter collaborated with the
leftists at the school to try and
sabotage the event based on what they
were posting on the internet it seems
that there was an attempt to reserve a
bunch of the tickets ahead of time
preventing people who wanted to actually
attend from from being able to attend
um but that plan proved futile as there
was a line stretching around the
building to get into the event and we
ended up having a packed house and it
was a great event um
the wannabe saboteurs were mostly
crowded out of the room
um by the sweet baby gang which showed
up in great numbers that didn't stop one
guy from making an attempt anyway about
a minute or two into my speech he stood
up on his desk with a rather bizarre
sign and i think that we were talking
about this afterwards it seems as though
he he thought
that some other leftist would join him
in this demonstration i don't think he
thought he'd be the only one but i i i'm
guessing they coordinated this ahead of
time and said okay we're all going to
stand up early in the speech and make a
big thing and but nobody else did it was
only him
um so we all just ended up having a good
laugh at his expense while he was
ushered out of the room rather quickly
but it was it was a lot of fun it was
good moments let's watch that here it is
well the most important thing to
establish for our purposes today is that
he is a man he is a he
and that will never change
that won't change
no matter what kind of uh
poster you hold doesn't change
that fact
at least the poster is laminated because
i saw some posters out there
i appreciate the effort
that's awesome some protesters out there
were holding signs on loose leaf paper
it's like come on
this guy he took the time to laminate
that thing with whatever that is
and i really appreciate it
like he had to go down to office space
or you know he had to go down to
to staples with that thing all right
anyway
leah thomas is a man back to the subject
in hand here
yeah i did appreciate the uh lamination
on the sign i mean obviously took a
certain pride in the work and i commend
him for that um but he he did make a few
mistakes like typing the letters in
white with a pink background making it
difficult to read what the sign actually
said
the sign apparently made some kind of
reference to um quote femboy furry porn
now
i don't know what that is
that guy apparently does know what that
is and felt the need to announce it to
the audience he wasn't the only leftist
in the audience i should say there were
a few others who uh perhaps
understandably chose not to join the
furry porn fan in his demonstration
instead they sat there at their desks
flipping me off at various points
throughout my remarks shaking their
heads in disapproval and finally
storming out of the room i actually
didn't notice any of this
that that even was happening i was told
about it later i didn't notice that they
marched out i just wasn't paying
attention to them the rest of the
protesters were outside being a bit more
vocal and explicit of course they
marched around with with signs uh
accusing me of being a fascist uh
chanting that i was killing children
somehow
they also reportedly chanted trans
rights are human rights for literally
five minutes straight i was told
um and as the attendees
people who were at my event as they left
they were accosted by the protesters
cussing them out and calling them
fascists as well
so to be clear
the audience members were fascists for
simply listening to what i had to say
i mean they they didn't even all agree
with me they just they just listened
and so listening to someone else's point
of view
is now fascism
because of course everything is fascism
at least though the protesters were so
that was that's kind of what you expect
fascist fu a lot of that kind of thing
the protesters were a bit more creative
with this chant though and i did
appreciate it play a clip too
matt can't swim
can't swim
can't swim
can't swim
can't swim
matt can't swim i mean first of all
that's a libelous accusation i i can
swim just very poorly it's more of a
more of a treading water sort of thing
doggy paddle kind of situation
enough that you know if one of my kids
is drowning i can jump in and save them
and i'm not going to drown alongside
them
um but that's that's about as far as i
can go i'm just not sure what any of
that has to do with the topic at hand
i wonder what insult they'll come up
with at my next event maybe they'll have
a chance mocking me for the fact that i
tend to overcook chicken breasts
maybe claiming that i don't know how to
fold fitted sheets
both of those would be true by the way i
just i don't you know i don't mean to
give them any ideas
in any case perhaps the most instructive
moment i thought came when one protester
who uh we should note put much less
effort into his sign
i think it looks like he stole a dry
erase board from one of the classrooms
and just wrote on the dry erase board
there's some efficiency there i guess
you can always change the message and
everything so i can appreciate that i
just i could have used a little bit more
color a little bit more flair in it but
um he was asked
by by someone who was there and twitter
account by the way is at rapid fire
underscore pod is the person who has
this uh got this footage for proper
attribution anyway asked like what what
is it about why are you here well you
know you've got this sign what what is
it that you don't like about this guy
what's the problem
and uh here's what he had to say i have
a sign over here that says
matt walsh tpusa talk to us about the
sign why is this important to you today
uh because i think matt walsh is an
idiot and dangerous to people
and yeah that's really all i have to say
on that number one thing matt walsh has
said that's pissed you off that made you
hold up that sign today oh god i'd have
to go back and look through his twitter
i know i see it all the time just give
me one i mean we're holding the matt
wall shine just give me one
trans women are not real women trans men
are not real men when it's proven by
science that trans women are in fact
women trans men are in fact men it
doesn't have to do with
your born sex it is that you feel like
you are
a woman and that's okay like you don't
have to conform to what
the society society so if you decided
that you wanted to identify as a woman
today is that something that we would
label him as he's a woman at that point
she's a woman she's a woman at that
point got it got to use the correct
pronouns all right so we've got women
trans women aren't women what about you
women are women well that matt walsh has
said that has made us hold this sign
today what about you what does matt
walsh say um let's see there's a lot of
stuff about um
january 6 like
honestly i get so confused with all
these right-wing tools
it's hard to keep track of who says what
but i know i've seen some stuff he said
and i know i wasn't a fan
i love how he's making no attempt to
project any confidence whatsoever about
what he says
um you know i don't like him because
matt walsh isn't idiots i think
and uh
dangerous
right he's dangerous that's what we're
saying about him okay
he ends all of his statements like when
there's a question mark at the end which
by the way is a problem
in general with young people today if i
might say uh they all tend to speak as
if the ends of their sentences all have
question marks uh but that's that's
that's another matter but listen he he
knows he's seen some stuff that's the
point and
he he knows i've he's he's seen some
stuff that i've said and it was not good
stuff
and that's all he needs to know
and he's not but most importantly he
knows that he's supposed to hate me and
so he does
also january 6th he throws in there
because everybody knows that i am a
famous supporter of the capitol riots i
i was actually at the capitol that day
doing uh doing a tap dance on top of
nancy pelosi's desk
i guess i shouldn't joke about that or
the feds are gonna bust down the door
any minute now anyway he was he has no
clue why i'm i'm terrible he just knows
that i must be the girl standing next to
him on the other hand at least quotes me
accurately uh she
is correct that i think trans women
aren't women because they aren't
she is of course incorrect in her claim
that science proves otherwise but one
attitude ain't bad
now
this all might seem pretty funny and um
it is no question about that but what's
the point
of going into these environments and
kicking out the hornets nests like this
as i mentioned yesterday my next stop is
going to be at unt where they chase the
last conservative speakers out of the
room
forcing them to hide in a closet
that's where we'll be going next now why
would i want to go there of all places i
mean why why do any of this what's the
point well one reason to go to these
places is that college campuses have
become extremely hostile to the truth
not just to open dialogue or to free
speech or whatever although it is
hostile to that as well of course but
for me that's not the main point the
main point is the hostility to truth
and wherever the truth is least welcome
is precisely the place where it's needed
most those are the places where we
should go
you know if you're talking to if you're
in an environment where
um
everybody agrees like everyone
understands basic common sense things
about biology and all of this
then some of these you know it's it's
still important to reinforce the truth
and to talk about it but um some of this
wouldn't be needed but it is
because of this hostility to truth so
that's one reason
another reason is that i'm i'm frankly a
stubborn antagonistic kind of guy and
when people tell me that i can't say
certain things or go certain places it
just makes me want to
go those places and say those things
even more but the other even more
important reason is that is that as i've
said before this is a very important
thing for us all to
to grapple with
that there is no
natural wake-up call coming
for these kids
okay the conservatives who've comforted
themselves with this notion
that uh it's just a bunch of silly kids
they're gonna get out into the real
world and they'll wake up pretty fast
the conservatives who think that have
been saying this for forever they're the
ones who are in for a wake-up call i
don't know why it hasn't happened yet
for them
these kids who are allergic to basic
truth
who chant fascists that anybody they
disagree with
who hate people like me even though they
don't even know why they hate me
these kids will be entering a culture
that is set up to keep them in that
state of delusion ignorance and fear
okay it has a a lot of older people are
in that same state
absolutely as we've seen especially over
the last two years but before that as
well
and so we can't wait around for people
to wake up
we have to go to them and wake them up
which means being a little aggressive
and perhaps confrontational
and even uh even rude at times
because the only other option is to let
them and millions more
remain stupefied and hypnotized forever
because that's what will happen
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends